[Music]
hello welcome to esophico visionaries me
sophie schabert nazi
staying connected has become more
important than ever now that we're
driven apart
how can 5g technology help us navigate
the unchartered waters of the
post-pandemic world i ask misha dollar
professor in wireless communications at
king's college london
mission dollar professor in wireless
communications and kings college london
great to have you with us
to be here all right so 2g 3g
4g i mean i don't remember any of them
creating such a sensation
as 5g networks and they say that 5g is
truly a game-changing setup in the
quality of connection why is it so i
mean because
we've had upgrades to speed and upgrades
to
reliability before why now why why such
fuss
yeah it's a good question you're raising
and it's it's really curious to see if
consumers will react really to the speed
improvement of 5g
because you know as we go on with the
generation from 2g to 5g
every time we improve the download speed
and the upload speed by a fact of 10
sometimes 100 which is really great
but uh would consumers care that they
can download now you know a netflix
movie whatever in three seconds rather
than 10 seconds
i'm not so sure so you know the
bandwidth is really good in 5g
but i think what is really the exciting
feature about 5g is the very low latency
so it's the time
you know between you typing a website uh
and
pressing enter and then getting the
response back now
whilst for human may not be so important
for websites and all this
but for anything which requires let's
say video engagement
or where machines need to talk to each
other this low latency is a
real real game changer and i think will
power a lot of totally prior unseen
applications
well you said 5g will give us the
so-called tactile internet being able to
transmit touch
which is obviously fantastic news for
people like me because i'm georgian and
i like to
hug and touch and keys and it was
deprived of all of these things during
the pandemic
but tell me how exactly is it going to
work
so the the tactile internet in fact
refers really to a very low latency
network so i've been pioneering another
internet which is called the internet of
skills
which allows you to transmit skills
through the internet so currently we can
only transmit video or audio
or text files now imagine a future where
actually i can do something through the
internet wouldn't that be great
and that includes also touch in
transmitting touch you know we do that
with uh
haptic gloves so there's quite a bit of
evidence in the internet on this
how i use that and we applied that for
instance in robotic surgery as one of
the applications
where a surgeon would do the robotic
surgery
remotely and would use a haptic glove to
feel
what he or she is actually you know
doing the operation on
so we see a lot of potentials there but
you need other equipment
apart from a very powerful 5g network
but how long do we all have tactile
internet in our homes
so that depends really on each country
so first of all of course the regulation
needs to be favorable the spectrum needs
to be released
so 5g will not work without you know the
right spectrum
in place then the investment needs to be
in place so because the 4g
equipment needs to be upgraded to 5g and
then the consumer appetite in the
industry appetite
needs to be ready so we see you know
different phases in um
in asia for instance we see the
regulatory framework very
very favorable investment variable and
consumers generally taking it up very
quickly
so there we will probably by 2023 we
will have a
fairly consistent rollout you know 5g
technology in the uk it's a little bit
later so you know by 2025
probably will have a very consistent
rollout now
you know for for let's say other parts
in the world will need to see it really
depends on this uh relationship between
the three factors
well i understand you're more focused on
the technical side of things but being
able
to not just see your vis-a-vis but also
like touch them despite being thousands
of miles
apart how will this transform
human communication i guess what i'm
asking is how will the
virtual version of face-to-face or hand
to hand
actually compete with the real life
experience and real people
that's a great question and i i
personally believe there will be a
massive shift really and i have
experienced that myself so i gave the
world's
first 5g concert where i was playing
the piano under the brunborger tour in
berlin and my daughter
she was singing in london the guild hall
and we were separate by a thousand
kilometers
and yet 5g brought us together within a
few milliseconds
and it felt as if she was with me and
that is really what will be the game
changer that low latency will create the
sensation of immediacy
will essentially synchronize realities
we will go beyond
augmented reality or virtual reality we
will go in the world of
uh synchronized reality and we as humans
were geared for
you know millions of years to build up
an emotional
bond when the communication happens
within 10 milliseconds
and skype and zoom and all that have
destroyed that because
it takes about 160 milliseconds just for
us to to talk
now if we are together in the same room
you know this emotional bond between us
is very different and 5g will bring this
back so i think there will be a massive
shift you know towards digital tools
remote working
change in demographics and and all that
will be powered within the first steps
by 5g
so right now communication over the
internet is basically looking
at the screen saying your image with the
speeds
offered by 5g will the 2d paradigm
change i mean what i'm asking is that
like
are we going to get like star strike
hologram calls or like
you know virtual reality streams through
sky
yeah so augmented reality is actually
you know augmented reality with
holographic combination
is really is really very close in fact
you know the very first smartphones are
being released to smartphones like these
where you hold them like that or you use
another phone essentially as
an intermediate screen and you see
holographic images
now if you think of that in the future
we could use applications which i have
on my phone for instance called clone
i do a holographic scan of my face and
that is then being projected into the
future
zoom type of capability so we could
literally have a fully holographic
3d fully immersive meeting happening
without being physically together and
that's a future which is coming very
quickly
he also said that the 5g speeds and the
new network's ability to
network's ability to send touch over the
internet will transform the education
all together what do you mean exactly
so education is clearly the learning
path so learning new new skills and so
far we have
great learning platforms but they're all
video or audio based or text based right
um and if you want to have something
more practical hands-on
for instance the surgeons at kings or
the dentists at kings
need to come to king's college in london
to learn how to do the surgery how to do
the drilling of the team
now the future with the internet of
skills and using this low latency 5g
capability allows us
now suddenly to offer learning platforms
where you can learn these
haptic skills you know the touch in the
muscle movement
through the internet and that will allow
us to skill up
at scale you know any any type of
profession you can think of where you
need a more practical slant to that
and in addition you can suddenly run
examinations
which are not any more subjective to
what the examiner sees
but actually subjecting in terms of how
the surgeon student moves the hand
how how he or she does the suiting so we
can
certainly not only power the learning
process
but also the examination process in the
future
well you you mentioned remote surgeries
how reliable
is 5g in that respect yeah so actually
we started talking about this
specifically me with proka does gupta i
was a pioneer in robotic surgery and
happens to be at
king's so we started the whole field and
um
you know initially i got a lot of uh you
know a lot of reservations also from the
press on that but uh
you know god was very quick as i say uh
because it's now becoming mainstream on
operational and china it's being started
to be used
now 5g we have designed 5g to be very
reliable
so we talking in terms of reliability
and how many
nines behind you know percentages you
have it is very reliable
uh but still we need to build in
mechanisms to make sure that if there's
a packet outage
that you know the robotic arm doesn't
move in the weird way so we
this is being done from uh from a
robotics point of view
but we also need to make sure that
security is very reliable
because you don't want anybody to hack
into it a live robotic surgery
and then cause havoc so we have a quite
a bit of
work still to be done to really make
sure that these systems are reliable
and are secure what else can be sort of
italicized with 5g i mean you talk a lot
about playing live music over the
internet with no lack
so that's a bonus what else i mean could
we remotely
control music we talk about medicine
um i'm also looking a lot into the arts
so i work with a lot of
a lot of artists and i'm a composer
myself and performing
pianist so the question is could we
democratize the way
how we essentially perform the arts how
we teach the arts you know
could i teach anybody in the world how
to play the piano
or somebody teaches me how to paint so
these type of capabilities you know will
be very important but specifically i
think
kobet brought it back with the with the
uh a star
artists in that they need to rethink on
how to
offer these immersive you know these
immersive kind of experiences
in a way which is different to to people
going to the stadium and listening to
them could you
for instance i don't know remotely
control a construction site
the future is i envisaged that for the
future to be exactly like that so you
would have a fairly cheap robotic outlet
with possibly an exoskeleton which is
then being controlled
essentially remotely uh from any other
part in the world and
we have demonstrated a very very
exciting use case which wasn't with
construction per se
but very similar that was with a drone
so we had a 5g drone and the majority of
5g drones has a 5g connection just to
the drone
but we did something else we connected
the control of the drone
uh you know to the united states through
a 5g slice as we
call it it went all the way back from
verizon to eebt
and then only controlled the drone so
what we wanted to show is that this
future internet of skills
using 5g technology allowed us to
control a very critical process
flying a very big industrial drone from
anywhere in the world
to anywhere else in the world so
therefore these type of applications
will hopefully become mainstream maybe
in five to ten years time
so basically like in ten years time you
can orchestrate a whole
war right i mean have like a telewarfare
planes and tanks and attack helicopters
and such
yeah we hope this will not happen so you
know it will
because it never happens without that
part yeah
any progress that we achieve we
always attain with that part so yeah
yeah probably you're right so i i
i have to reason with you so technology
has you know always been to some degree
used for for the worst part of humanity
sadly um a lot of that will actually
depend on our capabilities also to do
artificial intelligence
and so it's not only 5g and robotics
there needs to be a lot of ai involved
and currently at global scale there is a
a lot of discussions around you know
panels observer panels ethics regulation
and requirements on ai
so i think you know our ability as a
humanity to stop this to be used
uh you know within wars within conflicts
i think
really resides at these panels and i
hope they will be fruitful over the next
years to come
michelle we're going to take a short
break right now while we're back we'll
continue
talking to misha dollar professor in
wireless communications
at king's college london talking about
the 5g
and the prospects it holds for us stay
with us
[Music]
and we're back with misha dollar
professor in wireless communications at
king's college london talking about the
5g
misha since we started talking about
like the the downfalls of our
technological breakthroughs let's talk a
bit about the
darker side of internet and what will
happen to that part
once once we have 5g i mean do you feel
like we're going to have
more sophisticated spy and surveillance
systems
in the internet whatever is it because
we're fighting it right now right
we will know that we've lost our privacy
what's going to happen with 5g
yeah it's a good question and i think
you know the
the consumers in general generally
should be concerned about this and they
have all the right to be informed
now as you will know maybe you don't
know that but you know the ability for a
legal access to the infrastructure has
already been there as of 2g
so if you as a government or as a judge
or as a police or any other investigator
have a legal warrant
to access the data in a 3g 4g or 5g
system
this was always possible in fact this is
even standardized right
so there's no secret there now in terms
of illegal access
okay so basically the ability to hack
into this whether this is a
a government state or a malicious actor
or just some kids doing hacking
um in in 5g you know because it is a
fully software
system in principle this could become a
little easier
but at the same time what we have done
is we have also improved the security of
the
5g infrastructure so therefore we're
doing the best we can
to protect that infrastructure from that
type of malicious access
so i also wonder what kind of like
mobile tax advancements will be spurred
by the new speeds of g5 like
how will a 5g change the mobile phone
because when we had like
3g or 4g networks the mobile phone
makers rose up to new possibilities and
there was no point
in making like a smartphone with a huge
screen before
because you couldn't really stream
anything through slow internet
what about now how do you think it's
gonna transform
that's a great great question you're
asking and it's you know that that
actually reminds me of the sentence
which uh best hands westbrook the former
chief executive erickson the current
chief executive of verizon said
you know we started designing 3g when
the internet wasn't around
and we started designing 4g when the
when the smartphone wasn't around so
equally you know what's now 5g 16 why
are we doing that
and you're right and i think you know
the 5g capabilities bring it back to an
earlier part of the conversation
allows a lot of this holographic and you
know there's augmented reality
transmission
and therefore we need to adapt actually
the phones and uh there are a lot of
prototyping going on and i wouldn't be
surprised if you know iphone whatever 14
15 16
will have the capability for me to have
a holographic
image of you essentially as we speak so
much more natural engagement
and also people work actually on
vibration so
this haptic thing when you shop
something you go over the screen and you
touch it
and it vibrates depending whether that
is a piece of wood
or whether that is a you know cloth
you're buying so you can feel
on your smartphone what actually you
know you see on your screen
so these type of revolutions will
essentially
uh being enabled and accelerated for
that 5g technology
you know with the starling project
within a few decades
elon musk is planning to send 42 000
satellites to space that would be
able to bring free high speed low
latency
internet to even the most remote
areas on earth do you see starling as a
competitor to 5g
no starting is a great complementary
technology so
you know particularly you know we
struggle from a telecom point of view
to give business cases which allow us to
roll out this
technology with the same intensity in
rural and suburban areas
as we do that in the in the in the urban
areas
so therefore to have a capability which
allows us to
really globally ensure coverage no
matter where you are whether you're in
the outback in australia
or you're in siberia or you're in the
rainforest
you know still maintain a phone
connection i think that is very
very attractive and really underpins
that global footprint
of our wireless technology nearly half
of the world's population right now
don't have access to the internet
whatsoever let alone
5g or 3g and according to unesco
more than 800 million students kept out
of the classrooms
due to the pandemic and they have no
computers and more than 700 million
don't even have internet at home
and since 5g can't solve this problem
will it only
widen the gap between those who access
the new high speeds and those without
any access to it so potentially that
could be the case
if the government does not the
governments around the world don't
intervene
you know from a regulatory point of view
so quite a few governments including in
the united kingdom
have put out as a requirement for the 5g
license to ensure
that there's sufficient footprint in the
rural areas
which cover essentially these
underprivileged coverage areas
now that's that's one part of it 5g also
is not only about
a higher speed so interestingly some of
the frequencies we are using are the
very low frequencies where tv used to be
and as you know
for tv we just needed one big antenna
tower in the city
and it would cover essentially quite a
wide area
so therefore we would get you know not
the super duper 10 gigabits per second
5g
speeds everywhere but we would have at
least a decent coverage
to connect at schools to connect people
who want to learn from platforms
you know like udemy or coursera so i
think 5g gives us that opportunity but
it has to be made right the
economic case has to be there and
hopefully you know
the likes of elon musk will then also
cover the remaining part of
of these underprivileged areas so here's
the thing like with the 5g
not even rolled out yet there's already
talk taco 6g
what's that going to be like and also
like the way you describe 5g it just
sounds so
ultimate what could possibly be improved
in the new generation
so as an academic of course we're always
looking ahead in fact you know we worked
on 5g as
of 2012. so it was eight years in making
and uh naturally you know we started
working on 6g about you know nine months
ago
and the good thing is you know we have a
trend in telecoms which is fairly steady
so as we go from 2g
3g 4g 5g you know we we always improve
something by
one or two orders of magnitude and 6g
will be no different so i know how it
looks like i know
what type of data rate it offers what
type of feature it offers right
the thing we don't know is yet why do we
do that and
how are we going to going to do it right
so we currently work out roughly how
we're going to do it
and in a while we're going to start
thinking why we're doing it and
one thing i i could imagine is you know
that some of that network capacity or
capability in 6g
will be used more for for machines for
artificial intelligence
to maintain essentially you know it's
self-synthesizing structures but that is
a hypothesis
which we need to validate in a few years
time
so will there always be a ton of data
waiting to be moved around quickly
and thus like requiring constant new
generation tech for connectivity or
will there be like at some point some
kind of a g
like 7g or 23g i don't know after which
we will say
okay we got the internet working now no
more need for a new network
yeah you speak the right person here in
fact you know i was the first one to
advocate that you know
that generation salad as i call that
will stop at some point okay
and i had hoped it would stop with 5g
but clearly we're going on and the
reason i thought it would stop with 5g
is because we have completely
softwarised the infrastructure
in fact if you think about it telecoms
is probably the only
big ecosystem in place which still moves
in these
big generations every 10 years okay if
you think of the internet
you don't hear of a 5g internet or 10g
internet right because
we are everything is in software so
innovation happens much quicker and
happens in features right
and and therefore we hope to translate
that feature
of evolution uh you know into the telco
world
and 5g may not be yet the generation to
do it but i think 6g can do it and 7g i
think will be more cell synthesis
network
ag will consolidate it so i think ag
will be really our last g we will be
talking about
maybe you know in 30 years time we can
come back to this discussion we'll see
how it goes
uh-huh okay so even before the pandemic
there
have been a lot of conspiracy theories
about health risks 5g
may be causing but once the pandemic
struck i mean their number has
increased timefold and dozens of 5g
towers were
burnt in the uk and elsewhere around the
world
scientists have many times stated that
5g cannot
cause covate and other health conditions
as well
but false rumors about it continue to
spread why is it why is
where's this such a like black cloud
of bad rumors around 5g we've never seen
that before
well you know interestingly we had it at
every generation so you know
we had it at 3g we had a 4g we have a 5g
but there's a difference now to the 4g
and 3g
era we have a a social media world
which is you know not only exponentially
connecting everybody
but people have really become addicted
to this very kind of conspiracy
click-bait material
and you need to contrast that to the
fairly boring engineering videos which
are out there saying you know nothing
can happen
and you understand why this goes viral
so and i maintain for a long time
already we as an engineering community
we need to be a need to do better to
explain to society
why the technologies are are safe and
you know
before we fired out 5g this was like you
know
years and making almost a decade in
making and there's a whole body
responsible for doing nothing else but
uh checking whether the frequencies can
do any harm
the body is in a very non-sexy language
called irknips it's in the national
committee for non-ionizing radiation
protection
but if you go to the website it explains
it really well why
any of these frequencies we use in 5g
can cannot cause any harm it's it's a
very rigorous
methodology and in terms of covid
interestingly you know
people confuse correlation with
causality so one is when two things
happen at the same time
and the other is what happens what so
will you find areas where you have
both 5g and covet deaths
yes there are a lot of those but you
know will have 5g
cost that the answer is no because
they're countries like
iran where there's no 5g rolled out at
all we had a lot of casualties
and loads of areas in the uk or anywhere
else in the world where there's no 5g
deployed
and yet we had quite a few causalities
there so therefore
always make sure you don't confuse
correlation with causality
uh because really one does not cause the
other
can public outrage stall research i mean
can
people's erratic behavior and conspiracy
theories
have an impact on the research into the
connectivity
so that okay that's a difficult question
for me to answer
it's a very hypothetical question so i
think we we continue
uh doing the research we need to do to
advance you know technology
advanced society but i think what will
change and uh
i'm actually personally pushing for that
is to make sure that we get the message
right
so when 6g comes along that well before
6g is released we have enough
really interesting material made
available which explains to society
why this is a safe technology why
that is a good technology and why we
think it will really be important to
society
so i think that part of the exercise
will change
as a result of this very viral kind of
uh you know
outbreak we have seen with 5g well misha
thank you so much for this
really interesting insight into the
world of connectivity
and the breakthroughs that we're in for
in the nearest future and i hope all the
best in your
future endeavors and your research into
the high tech
thanks a lot thank you cheers
you